欢迎收听古爱,我是孟宫
本期节目由善存叶黄素赞助
每天跟盘研究财报追踪市场消息
你的投资组合在升级
但保养有跟上吗?
投资要做功课
保养当然也不能只靠感觉
今天跟大家分享
理财神器善存叶黄素
善存采用美国专利Flora GLO
游离型叶黄素好吸收高17%
而且一天只要一颗
就能够轻松补充20毫克叶黄素
效率做好有生保养
重点是善存叶黄素成分精研究
不止三周看见不同
更有超过百篇科学研究发表
如果你是忙碌上班族常常出差
或是不喜欢吞胶囊的人
也可以选择善存新推出的
叶黄素精华冻
四合一水量配方含叶黄素
玉米黄素 虾红素与花青素
帮助尽量有神滋润补给
Q弹果冻口感酸甜好吃
攜带方便
不管上班旅行还是全家一起补充都很适合
投资市场讲究长期布局
保养也一样
趁这次momo限时又会把叶黄素一次补好补满
现在下单善存叶黄素胶囊或是精华洞二入组组
也就是加码送你二合挺立盖28订
买二送二简直不要太划算
投资股票也不用投资自己的健康
详细资讯和商品连结的方案
资讯有兴趣的朋友可以点进去看看
那昨天参加了一场蛮有趣的活动
是Startup Spheres举办的关于AI科技跟娱乐相关的一个论坛
那这个Panel Talk它是全英文的一个模式
所以我一开始是有点紧张啦
因为我虽然算是会讲英文
可是我並沒有在公開場合去講英文
甚至是要跟幾個講者
要交互、要分享這些想法
這樣的經驗是沒有的
所以其實一直在想說
會不會有可能跑去雷人家之類的
但是後面看起來是還好啦
非常感謝Charles的邀請
非常感謝相關團隊
有看到我們硝南資本
讓我們去跟同台的像是Kevin Lin
他是Lifelike的Founder
然後他以前是Hooch的創辦人
然後再來另外一位是Sony Ventures的Katsusan
所以就是跟這些大咖們一起去討論
關於在AI科技或娛樂相關的內容
對我來說是收穫非常的大
這個活動我覺得本身也算是
持續的幫我們肖南資本去獲得更多的一些關注
其實我們目前是沒有任何對外募資
或者說我們需要跟市場找錢的一個動機是零
因為我們自己本身其實就算還有蠻有錢的
我們股東的大家都是很願意再持續的投入
目前我們的Portfolio的表現也都還蠻不錯
一個未公開的遊戲獲得巨大的成功在海外另外一個已公開的遊戲Rubonite獲得了3000個然後現在都是壓倒性好評在各地的市場都有很好的一個feedback所以我覺得我們目前的前途
看起來還蠻光明的
大家也都是非常相信
我們是在做一件對的事情
所以其實到這個論壇上
我知道大家會聚焦要聊的東西
是AI會怎麼樣去改變這個社會
現在對AI的投資
其實絕大多數人的直覺認知
就是你要盡可能把錢丟進去AI
特別是像我們自己在刺激市場跟股票市場的
你知道在過去一陣子
只要你的東西跟AI沒有關係
基本上你就很難漲
除非像最近的金融股非常的雄猛
這個我們就不會參與到
因為其實跟我們的領域有蠻大的差距
但絕大多數
就來說你是做零組件的
科技業的
如果你沒有沾到AI的話
你過去的performance就不好
所以其實在刺激市場裡面
我們已經是花了大量的時間去做
我們甚至把它稱為是momentum trading
就是一個動能的交易
我們知道說AI相關的東西
甚至有些東西我們不求聖結
我們不一定要知道它在幹嘛
我們只要知道說
OK它就是正在這一波浪潮上面
然後它可能會有AI的exposure
那你就可以去買它了
因為你知道未來的東西
你很難去具體化
等到你已經完全可以具體化跟想像的時候
其實那個股價滿多時候就漲完了
那所以因為我們在四級市場
已經做了很多
這種偏向動能交易
或者一些想像的東西
那當我們進入初級市場的時候
因為我們假設要想像要動能
我們本來的工作都可以做
所以我們到初級市場
我們反而是反過來
我們去做價值投資
我們去真正的了解團隊
我們去非常深入的去知道他們的pipeline
大概長什麼樣子
以及他們想要做的東西是什麼
更多人與人之間的接觸
那我們進去就是我們在長頭的
我們在深蹲
我們希望跟著公司一起compound
一起複利上去
這個是我們的目標
所以我們會非常的有耐心
我們是一個evergreen fund
做的事情其實跟本來在
刺激市場做的東西算是相反
所以它是一個非常有趣的體驗
在這種論壇上面
當然大家就會花蠻多的心力去聚焦在
AI是怎麼樣去創作更多的內容
甚至有一個說法是說
因為我們現在有AI tooling
大量的AI platform之後
其實像是user generated media
或是說一些創作者
他們現在有了非常強大的工具
他們可以讓整個內容產業通膨
就是content inflation
它會產生問題是什麼
就是abundant
大量的內容
cheap便宜
因為怎麼講大家都可以產出
所以會給人家一種感覺
內容是不是在後面會不值錢我相信在AI剛出來的時候可能2023、2024真的有蠻多人有這樣子的想法但現在我們已經走到2026我相信你各位的想法應該是跟我差不多
就是你直接就看得出來說
一個內容它到底有沒有靈魂
然後就算你用AI去輔助創作
這個我是覺得還好
雖然網路上已經有很多那種反AI分子
他只要發現說某個遊戲工作室
或是某一個什麼畫漫畫畫圖的
或是一些手遊的裡面的一些插畫
你用了AI他們就會去抵制你
他們就很討厭
但我是比較像中性的
我會覺得說你去使用AI作為工具可以
可是如果我發現說你整個遊戲
就只是因為你知道像它這個類別是很紅
你就用AI去硬拷一個東西出來
這種東西你馬上就聞得出來
而且你會非常的倒彈
你會很討厭
你會覺得說他媽有夠噁
然後這個團隊以後你就再也不會看它了
所以我覺得我們現在進入一個
非常講究信任的時代
信用超級重要
雖然信用在以前就很重要
但在這種內容爆發的時代裡面
信用变得特别的重要
非常的重要
而且以前的信用是
可能回掉之后
我们都知道很难重建
然后当然对
有办法慢慢的把它堆回来
可是在这个时代
因为你选择太多了
所以你信用回掉
你大概一辈子就回掉了
所以是一个非常需要
去珍惜你羽毛的时代
千万不要想要赚快钱
然后把你的名声砸掉
因为以后大家都找得到
所有东西都会留下记录
所以在我们的认知是
虽然没错
我们知道说
content inflation
还有大量的content在外面
有很多的游戏图片
因為AI的一個撲破發展導致大量的灌出來
但它並沒有讓我們產生選擇的障礙
不知道大家感受有沒有
就是我並沒有產生選擇障礙
就像說我還是知道說
我要看電影
我要看哪幾個導演的東西
我要玩遊戲
我要玩哪幾個製作人
或是說哪幾個studio的東西
因為他們推出來的東西
就是很認真在做
他們很認真的在裡面打磨
這個是我要的東西
所以我相信就即便大家現在的
public consensus是認為
contact會變得不值錢
我們覺得說這可能是一個錯判
就類似那時候說Suspocalypse
會殺掉所有的軟體
隔了一兩年之後才證明說
根本沒有這樣子的事情
一定有東西會被淘汰掉
就像我們的老生常來
硬體也有東西被淘汰掉
你不要都想要一桿子打翻一船人
如果你用這樣的方式去分析的話
其實會掉入蠻多陷阱的
一樣的道理就是
當然這些大量的內容產出
它勢必會對一些創作者
造成一個排擠的效應
可是它反而會讓那些很認真去創作的人
在這樣的一個時代
你會像是一個非常閃耀的燈塔一樣大家都會發現你的存在所以像我們蕭蘭資本裡面的一些Portfolio一個未公開的遊戲團隊在海外獲得巨大的成功
甚至有很多的粉絲會自願的幫他去做一些
相關的周邊有趣的東西
這個蠻酷的
公開的案例像是我們Rubinite
他獲得了3000壓倒線好評
他後面的評價數量是很快的衝上去
然後在全球市場都獲得一個巨大的成功
其實我是相信說他隨時都有機會在試過
只要哪一個海外的實況主
發現這麼經典這麼讚的遊戲
有可能他跑去播了之後
又會有很多新的風潮跑出來
所以他會變成是一個長尾的IP
我覺得在後面其實會有蠻多這種發揮空間
所以我們不認為說因為有大量的AI工具
就會導致內容通膨導致內容不值錢
對 他會有大量的內容
可是內容不會變得不值錢
反正是好的內容會變得更加值錢
因為大家真的是受夠了那些出資爛造的東西
這個可能是我們在市場上的一些看法
我分享的另外一個觀點是
在過去我們都知道說台灣是一個島國
所以其實有蠻多人都在倡議說要國際化
要 more international 或什麼的
其實像這樣的東西
這個小時候我們一定也都受影響過
你要好好地把一些語言學好
這我也是非常的認同
再來就是說你要多看一點什麼海外的報導
有一段時間就跟大家講說
你一定要每天看CNN
你要每天做什麼
之後大家就發現說
大家就發現說
一些那種海外的主流媒體
其實你知道每個人都還是有一些意識形態
但是有些人的意識形態是強到
就是他認為只有他的想法是對的
那你有任何其他的想法
他就會幫你蓋一個印章
他就會幫你去貼上一些標籤
那他其實已經變成是某種程度上的病毒了
所以你是把境外的病毒引進來
所以並不是說什麼跟國際接軌
就一定是比較好的
你要看你是跟什麼東西接軌
那再來呢
其實國際化後來講到最後
他會變成是一種空談
就是說我很國際化
我直接就要看海外的東西
那你到底做了什麼事情
對吧 你就只是一個談資
對不對 就跟很多人
把AI當成是談資
是一樣的道理
你沒有辦法把它用到你的工作
你沒有真的進入到資本的運作
其實很多時候你就只是講講
你就只是聊聊
在我現在看來
真正的國際化是什麼
像最近的幾年就是國際化
就是台灣的一些資本工廠
它跑到各地去設廠
它跑到各地去投資
這個就是一個很屌的
國際化的一個實踐
台灣的資本市場在全球排名
我記得前陣子是跑到第四第五名去
你可以想像嗎
台灣這麼小的一個地方
我們的上市櫃MarketCap
加起來竟然是全世界第四第五名
這是他媽殺小
大家一直在討論說要怎麼樣讓海外的investor
senpai notice me 要讓senpai看到我們
沒有 現在其實是我們要不要去看別人
是別人要進來問說我們要不要去投資他們
所以像我在昨天一個蠻特別的體驗
是有好幾位海外的founder
在會後來跟我遞名片
希望我可以看一下他們的團隊
這個就是我們想要看到的一個東西
我認為說其實台灣是一個資本豐沛的地方
當然我們的環境還是相對的保守
我覺得那在一個轉換期
就類似說可能有時候我們看到一些
歐美的生活型態或怎麼樣的
你想說為什麼台灣不能夠像我們那樣
沒有那就是說你有錢一陣子之後
你可能就會長得像那樣子
然後接著你就會慢慢的往下走
反正就是一個不好的環境
會產生非常堅韌的人
那堅韌的人就會產生很多的錢
產生好的環境
那好的環境就會再產生
可能就是嬌生冠養的一群人
然後我們就開始產生一些奇怪的想法
然後這些也會進入不好
所以它是一個循環
我覺得現在我們就是在一個非常強大的風口浪間
大家在往上爬
所以我們不用過度去聚焦說
怎麼樣讓海外的人看到我們有什麼
因為這也很虛
這到底在講什麼
而是你怎麼樣讓台灣的人願意去投資
我覺得這樣就好了
所以像我們消產資本在做一件事情
就是我們想要去證明給資本市場看
你是可以去投資一些台灣的新創團隊
內容團隊
並且獲得收益的
這個IP catalog它是值錢的
它是一個long term asset
它並不是說
就只是一個夢想好玩
丟進去可能一下子就會不見
或是有一堆詐騙的人在裡面
沒錯它確實是需要一些整頓
但是我們有非常多厲害的團隊
你知道我們前面的那些大前輩們
像是Sigono
然後像是Red Candles
像是赤足
非常的強大
然後帶著後面的團隊
就是一波一波的出來
我覺得就是那種母雞帶小雞的感覺
然後我們能夠做什麼
因為我們不會做遊戲
我們不會開發遊戲
但是我們會什麼
我們會搞那個infrastructure layer
我們會幫你去把最難的募資給弄好
合約不會簽是不是
然後這個代理商不知道怎麼找
我們都會有一些人脈
可以幫忙大家把這些事情做好
所以你們做你最會的東西
我們去做你不會的東西
我們結合在一起嗎
天下無敵
我覺得我覺得這個是很有機會的
如果說有人願意下來
像我們這樣子去證明給大家看
因為你在這之前你沒有案例嗎
沒有案例大家不會相信嗎
就可能講到一些產業
大家講說那個是詐騙
因為就是沒有案例
所以我們在做的事情
就是我們希望可以去創造一些案例
那我们认为不一定一定要从可能国外搬前进来我们就是在国内像我们自己像我自己都还愿意再继续争执下去因为我就是看到希望我觉得你知道就跟人在生活中
生命中一样
你必须要看到有蜡烛在镜头等你
就是如果说前面都是黑的话
那大家都不敢走啊
那如果你看到蜡烛在那边等你
即便看到蜡烛的人是很少数人
但是我一直在往前走
你看到我在往前走
你可能想说我可能可以尬广跟上
我觉得大家都会想要跟着上来
这个是我们想要去证明的
我们想要去把它做好的
所以台灣是一個非常大的消費者
在過去在遊戲界
其實像是在手遊裡面
馬上是全世界第七名
那你知道用人均來看是非常高的
因為我們人口這麼少
然後再來就是如果你要看
整個遊戲產業的一個規模的話
我們應該也有個3到5B以上的一個規模
所以其實台灣是非常強大的消費者
累積了一群會玩遊戲
會去看動漫
會喜歡這種什麼二次元有的沒有的人
非常會消費也很有錢
我們想要證明的是
我們也可以當一個非常好的創作者
當然其實在十幾年前就有啦
我們小時候都玩一些什麼先見或什麼的嘛
只是現在是一個新的風潮
我覺得很多的indie game
很多SingleA跟AA的Studios
會在這一波會冒出來
為什麼
因為他們可以去槓桿
這些新的AI
有點像是說
我們平常聊的半導體
我們知道說
IC Design House
Fabulous
他們有Fab
他們就去做設計
然後他會有一些EDA tool
有一些拼圖可以給他去做使用
接著他找到Foundry
去幫他生產晶片
然後再找到Offset
然後組裝廠把東西做出來
其實一樣的一個模式
其實現在在這些新創遊戲
我覺得我們也是有看到
他們就是這些Design House
然後他使用的這些Fab
就是AI相關的工具
它的EDA tool就是那些開發的引擎
這些東西都是可以用租的
然後再來 distribution layer
我們直接交給Steam去做
30%沒問題
還是很快樂的給你
你幫我打到全世界去
而且像我們自己的遊戲
都上過Steam的排行榜
然後跟在Steam的首頁有出現
所以這個對我們來講
是一個非常強大的曝光
所以現在的創作者
他們其實在一個很幸運的時代
就是你不要被表象給蒙蔽了
好像說AI工具讓大家都可以創作
沒有你如果真的有靈魂的東西
現在是一個極好的時代
你可以用小成本
然後所有東西都租的
你知道以前
你可能開發一個遊戲
你要自己架伺服器
要找多少人
工程師一堆
現在你可能去用便宜的方式
你去租用這些工具
新的科技
你就可以把你的東西
推到全世界去
其實它就會把一個產業
從本來的
類似說是Heat Driven就是我丟一個東西如果說沒有中的話我可能就直接倒了就buy了這樣可是在我們資本加入的運作之下是我們可以點點成心
星星之火燎原
我就是每個東西丟一點
然後最終我們一定會有辦法
就打進去遊戲的那些名人堂裡面
然後成為Steam上面歷久不衰的IP
後面產生的長尾就是非常的恐怖
所以它一定是一個可以做的模式
那只是我們必須要證明給大家看
那也希望在未來的幾年
可以去證明這件事情
他可能算是我近年最重要的一個目標
那這邊稍微跟大家分享
這次去Start of Spheres的一些感受
也非常感謝我這樣的機會
可以跟這麼多厲害的人通台
大概這樣子
好那九月至今雖然才五天
但就是一個非常震盪的盤
然後也蠻難搞的
就是說如果你今天是想要做動能的話
你應該
我覺得可能短短在幾個禮拜內
應該就輸掉蠻多錢的
因為形態上去你就必須要追
這個交易就是這樣子做
掉下來你又要再把它解碼再砍掉
反而是那些可能傻傻抱著
你會注意到你在過去的一段時間
其實你的禁止
應該甚至會是慢慢的往上墊的
就是說這個盤子可以做的
只是你如果用4到7月的
那段時間的做法去做的話
就會持續的沒有錢
這也是我們在過去一陣子
去跟大家提醒的
當然其實我們不知道
什麼時候會轉回動能
等到盤真的就轉回動能的時候
那些持續做的
他一定會收穫到最多
然後等到其他人發現說
如果等一下又回去可能四到七月亮的盤的時候
他們又會再一次的追在相對的高點
這就是為什麼很多人前不後繼都會持續的去做某一些策略
你不能夠在盤不好的時候就拒絕去做
你可以把不會縮小
你可以有一些瘋狂
可是你理論上還是要持續的去做
所以會稍微的辛苦一點
最近的一些財報數字
像是Broadcom
它其實是開得非常好
然後它裡面聊到了蠻多有趣的內容
它每次都會有一些經典的輿錄
像之前是講說Ankle Biters
就你們這些小朋友在後面那邊咬我的腳
這次在講說
Outer Mongolia的學生
兩個學生一個是 Anthropics
一個是 OpenAI
他們要去念書
你各位要幫幫他
他六個客戶裡面
他說不是每個我可能都會
要幫他去想辦法搞錢
只有兩個要這樣
這兩個就是
因為畢竟他們還沒有上市
當然 Anthropics後來上市之後
這個環境一定會稍微變好
可是OAI的話
因為財務數字是沒有這麼公開的
所以他們去融資的話
這個其實我們在像
Bank of America的私訪NVIDIA的memo裡面
我們有看到類似的東西
就是說這兩家公司因為信用的問題然後在市場裡面算是一個new player所以他們其實拿到的融資的deal都沒有這麼好於是就會有像是Broadcom或是像是NVIDIA
就會下來協助這件事情
讓他們至少可以先把設備做出來
我覺得站在Broadcom的角度的話
他現在非常有動機要很大力的去扶Amphlopics
因為Ionwood一堆是Shift到阿納
之後的V8i跟後續的Google的晶片
可能蠻多人也是往那個地方丟
所以去把外蒙古的學生好好地養好
然後送進大學 送進研究所
然後最後面成功的依景還鄉
這個可能是Block Kong在後面
會持續努力的一個方向
所以我們看下來就是在
不管是大家很擔心的什麼Seller Financing
或是說是不是螺旋圈圈
大家都在互相投資
是不是說需求是假的
我們在每次的財報
其實看下來都覺得說
需求是千真萬確的強大
這個沒有什麼太大的問題
當然其實最主要的核心
還是放在Frontier Lab
Frontier Lab之下可能去交出最多貢獻的
所以他們必須要持續的往前衝
但是整體看起來其實都還算是蠻健康的
而且最近其實Rumor有聽到說
微軟明年的CAPEX會開很高
就是沒有要停下來的意思
大家都持續衝
因為這個東西就是真的會賺錢
Brockhawk也算是第一次給出的那種
偏中長期的指引
那些數字其實看到下有很多鈍化了
反正就一堆都是加100%以上
表現得非常好
當然可能開了這些數字之後
一定滿多人就會很納悶說
我覺得很納悶說為什麼不會漲
這個我覺得就是現在相對難處理的一段
因為你知道其實在過去AI不是沒有漲
AI漲很多
好像已經是AI的第三年
要往第四年去了
我們講了說在資本市場給大家看到
然後開始爆紅的這段時間起算
對一些研究人來講
這可能是第十年之類
但對我們在資本圈看的話
是差不多是三到四年左右
所以其實有一堆東西都已經是翻倍再翻倍
已經是漲很多了
所以我們並不會覺得說
每份財報都理論上一定要讓大家大噴
這也是為什麼
其實我們還是會去選擇一些動能交易的主因
因為我都知道你很好
可是你不會漲的話
對我們這種做交易的人來講說
我又不是每個東西都想要來
buy and hold 然後去長投對不對
就有些東西我可能一爆
就是一整年都沒有收益
你說台積電很好
台積電就是已經在過去幾個月
可能就是沒有給你收益
當然我們盡量不要去看太短
只是以交易的角度
就是你會去找一些
就是他有進攻機會的東西
最近是有發生說一些進攻機會的東西
其實都是比較沒有那麼香的
就是它其實已經算是市場的
相對後線的一些題材
但因為它相對沒有被拉過
所以大家趕快去拉這些東西拉到補給
只是我們相信可能大家都拉到相當程度之後
你最終還是會回歸到那些在Fundamental是持續開很好的
所以這些比較大咖的玩家
我自己本身是不太擔心的
上次有跟大家聊到說我會想要再持續的去觀察
可能Broadcom是怎麼樣去評論
抱歉說因為我們在上集有聊到NVIDIA
跟MediaTag的一個投資
這些事情對他來講一定都會有一定程度的影響
看他們怎麼去評論這件事情
這次蠻有趣的是過去其實Broadcom的Hawk
他在數個電話會議裡面
他算是蠻親視他的對手
就包含說叫我們是Ankle Biters
然後我會提說有些人在talk shit
就是明明沒有什麼多少東西
競爭也打不贏我們
然後卻一直在外面講說
他們拿到什麼訂單
但這是他第一次把MediaTag拿出來講
所以這其實在我的想法是
如果今天是按照差不多一兩季錢的市場的話
MediaTag應該要再給他一根
為什麼
因為就是你直接被一個晶片的王者
Asic晶片的強者去證明說你是對手
他以前都不想提你們的
然後以前都講說
你們在talkshare你們沒有訂單
他直接講說你就是有東西
但是我東西還是比你好
像這樣子就是代表media tech
我覺得某個程度上升華了
就是你進入到另外一個圈子
雖然其實我們一直都知道
它是很強大的公司
可是至少現在市場中的一個王者
就認知到你的存在
然後還要talkshare about you
因為如果我真的覺得
你不是什麼東西的話
我會像以前那樣子
我根本連題都懶得提你
但我會拿出來提
代表你是對手
這就類似說我們在過去幾年看到
像那些什麼Tesla殺手
為什麼都要講說Tesla殺手
為什麼都要講是蘋果殺手跟NVIDIA殺手
因為它是最強的嘛
最強的才需要被殺嘛
你要搶它的市場嘛
所以當我需要把你拿出來提的時候
其實對你來說是利多啦
所以我的想法是
它等於是幫聯發科開了一個
法術會的感覺
證明說它的東西可以
就即便它嘴巴上講說
它的東西可能會比較慢啊
或什麼的
這個跟我們考察到的
其實也是類似的
就是確實
那個晶片出來的速度
會跟大家想像的
有一些落差
但無論如何
其實你知道公司
他們在預期管理上面
也是非常的厲害
就是他們滿多時候
不會把話說滿
就像說我看到20B的訂單
我就告訴你15B而已
簡單就是說我是低爆
然後高beat
我就是要讓市場有驚喜
所以因為說
雖然有些地研是真的會發生
有可能會對財務衝擊沒錯
但也因為這些公司
他們蠻多會去做這種預期管理
所以它可能本來就低爆了
甚至最後面還是會超出你的預期
就即便說真的發生地研
但還是超出你的預期
因為它本來的數字又低爆
這個就是稍微給大家的一些小小暗示
就在市場裡面其實蠻多時候
會看到這樣的一個情形所以在我們看來Broadcom的各種數字然後或是它的fabric因為現在蠻多人關注的是光通跟互聯相關的內容其實指引跟整個方向都是給的非常好
為什麼股價不漲
我們就不用太花時間去討論這樣的議題
就有點類似像Vidia前陣子不漲
可是時間到了可能就還是會動一下這樣子
所以我相信進入AI的一個
我們不能夠說是
以產業的角度來講是什麼階段
因為這個還太難判斷
甚至大家都覺得說是在可能很早期
可是以資本來說
它畢竟就是一個循環
某個程度上我覺得
現在可能就是進入一個那種
怎麼說
AI可能是一個像網路
非常長的趨勢
可是它一定有一個像前面
非常用力的去佈置光線
然後最後面那個.com泡沫
大家知道就是那時候
你任何一個.com的網站
可能都可以募到錢
然後它會掉下來
最後面長期趨勢網路是好的
可是資本市場是會這樣上上下下
我覺得我們家可能就是在中間的一個休息段
然後後面搞不好還有一段大的
可是一定會有一天
就是它就是會砸下來這樣子
只是要怎麼樣在這裡面
持續的去找到獲利的機會
那個難度可能就會稍微的提升
但是如果放就是你只要一直去跟著
那些獲利實際在改善的東西
其實就沒有什麼太大的問題
就是你事後回頭看就發現說
你都還是賺錢的
只是你在短期內要去抓到什麼東西
會噴出去
那個難度我覺得變得越來越高
除非說可能下半年的某個時間點
又再次回到動能的盤面
不然可能相對的有挑戰
所以花太多心力去解釋
因為我現在看到很多報導
因為看到Block Kong的股價沒有漲
就去解釋說為什麼它不好
因為什麼樣客戶
顧於依賴
或者說誰搶市場
那個東西如果你看多
它其實會影響到你的一些判斷
就是你可能心中就會幫它
畫上一個茶
可是其實不是
它就只是不會漲而已
還沒漲而已
但不代表它的基本面數字
是不會開上去
特別是公司已經算是泄體
就直接給你看它的guidance
所以在我的角度就是
你要有更多耐心
你現階段要去做這些big names
最大的一個挑戰是
你就是要有耐心
你就是要願意蹲
但是反正成績會出來
理論上我們知道股價
它終究就是跟著EPS的趨勢在跑
就是這樣
除非那種非常短期的話
當然它會因為一些消息
一些催化什麼會有變化
所以其實就是聚焦在
比較長遠的目標
可能這樣子
在這陣子的一些股票市場裡面
會比較順利一點
我自己也知道動能難做
因為有找到一些機會
然後上去撸車如果發現說隔天大家都不玩的就丟下來那時候就只好被迫撿嘛所以有點像說現在在動能的這個部位就是你做越多就有可能會賠越多那真的有辦法噴出去的
可能是比較少數的幾個案例這樣子
那我還是相信說這個局面應該會改善
因為其實你去注意說像加權
它是越電越高
就是大家講說我們第二隻腳沒有
它就後來就直接就上去了
那現在就再一次的回到那種
就是快到錢高的位置
所以理論上如果有人帶頭衝出去的話
大家就是會重新的回到那種多頭行情的感覺
其實我覺得
我在兩禮拜前就覺得說差不多了
他應該要表態
他要決定說他到底要往上來往下
就是至今要決定的
但就是一直在拖
所以拖到會有點尷尬
我的做法是反正就是把槓桿再縮
就縮到小一點
然後就在那邊等待
等到真的很明確的時候再來做
因為你本來想要去搶快車
就是很容易會被修理到
它會變得是比較難處理
但整體來說盤不差
但你會注意到像我自己身邊的朋友的意見就很兩極
有些人你就感覺他是心灰藝人
可以想說你到底要心灰藝人三小
指數位置在這麼高
然後一堆東西都走出去
他們會心灰藝人就只是單純
因為用過往的一個pattern去做
你就是會賠錢
因為你就是沒有辦法在這陣子這樣做
我當然未來不排除
所以他可能卡住的點是在這一邊
那再來其實市場上也有一些機會在醞釀中
像最近Tesla他們講說
他們Cybercat裡面用到馬達是完全沒有用稀土
其實這個我就覺得有可能會在供應鏈
或是相關的一些議題上面去產生機會
就是說如果AI的東西真的距離橫盤的話
其實大家會開始往外圍的東西去找
那這一塊其實蠻屌的
就是它不用稀土
然後還是可以跑出非常好的一個效能的話
真的證明說他們真的是工程天才
非常的強大
當然CyberCap也有一些相關的 supply chain可以看
只是在現階段
因為你要找到Growthrate這麼強大的東西
還在AI
所以我直接把它當一個次題材
就稍微再關注一下
那就亦或是類似
我也有去關注一些軟體
只是軟體它現在算我的Portfolio裡面不是特別大宗的東西
大家會稍微看一下
像前陣子就聊到說Salesforce跟Amphorbit合作
那最近Snowflake大家看到他們的成績跟數字又再次的往上調
非常的強大
直接去總結它就是它最厲害的一環就是在做AI的協作
它讓客戶可以相信
把資料可以放在他們這邊是沒有什麼太大的問題
所以其實跟Salesforce那邊我們得到一些情報是類似的
就是現在資料治理怎麼樣去做分門別類
哪些東西上映哪些東西維持在地端
這是非常重要的
在裡面我也獲得一些重要的情報
像是他們有提到說他們的客戶如果是使用預設的模式所以預設模式就是讓Snowflake這邊去決定說你問的問題或是你提的需求
我用哪一個模型去處理
所以類似說router是放在公司這邊
讓公司決定要去支用哪一個模型
這邊它就可以產生很不錯的毛利
簡單來講就是說
可能客戶預設就是我一個request要付出10塊錢
但實際上我只花了5塊錢
這5塊錢就是我賺到的
但其他的如果你指定說哪一個模型的話
它比較類似是
我覺得另外一個模型是13塊
我其實是Sony15塊之類的
那個價格的毛利
就會比較窄一點比較薄一點
所以這也解釋了
就是我之前在使用
Perplexity Computer的時候
我也好奇
我去使用各式各樣的模型
實際上它的獲利的結構長什麼樣子
然後在Snowflake這邊算是獲得了一個印證
所以只要客戶越來越相信這個平台
然後他也意識到說
如果說由我自己去選擇模型
像我現在一個痛點是
我知道有些問題
我拿去問我的AI模型
它會幫我去做太大程度的深蹲
它一個問題很簡單的東西
我一回頭發現說
哇靠你給我跑了五分鐘了
五分鐘都是錢啊
所以如果我知道
我可以透過一個可信任的平台
不管是B2B的business
可能是Snowflake
然後或者說B2C的話
是我今天使用Propelastic Computer
假設我可以很完全的相信說
它的router會幫我去分佈到最好的模型的話
對我來講
我也覺得我花出沒有這麼多錢
對它來講
它也可以在我身上賺到更多的錢
它有更大的一個溢價權利
他可能跟模型商這邊的利潤分配
又會調得更好
所以這個可能會進入後面
不管是在軟體或是在模型商之間的
一個利潤爭奪的重點
在Snowflake這邊我們也注意到
他跟進的像是Panter
或是其他軟體相關的公司
他們在做的事情
就是 Forward Deployment Engineer
大量去鋪這樣的一個職業
這些人其實就是PM加工程師的一個合體
可以這樣想
就是他要進去真的了解大家的流程
每家公司的流程不一樣
每家公司在意的點不一樣
他要去理解你要幹嘛
然後接著呢
甚至他也有一點Sales的成分
然後接著去Pitch給這家公司
我可以怎麼樣去幫你報
所以FDE可能在這波趨勢裡面
在過去已經是很常被大家提到
可是我覺得後面一定會在持續的放大
就是像這種比較通財類型的人
他可能變成是新型態的一個工作
很主要的增長的需求來源
以前我們可能知道說
每個人都分分別類
你是做會計 你是做業務 你是做coding
但現在可能在AI的幫助之下
每個人在每個類別裡面都可以做到60分
所以誰可以把這些東西整合得很好
可能就類似說我們剛剛講有些
AI的interface
他可以把router這一塊處理的很好
我就會相信他
所以其實那個道理是一致的
就是我去相信這些router
跟我相信這些fde是一樣的道理
如果說有一個很強大的fde
他可以把我的需求全部都包好整理好
然後去給我一個方案
然後真的去解決問題的話
他就會獲得巨大的成功
所以很有趣的是
跟我們開頭的東西
好像某個程度上呼應的
大家都相信說在AI時代
產出暴力或什麼的
那個是大家要去聚焦的機會
反而是內容本身的品質
好像大家沒有這麼在意
但是它是反過來了
內容的品質就是因為東西爆量了
abundant了
所以大家會在意說
你到底做出來的東西是好是壞
所以誰可能找了比較多的FDE
誰的訓練流程比較好
這種比較直化比較人文的東西
說不定會變成後面的一個重點
我覺得也是這些軟體業者
要去競爭的一個核心
所以這方面可能也是一個
算是中型的趨勢
是可以稍微的看一下
最近在市場上就是有發現
這樣的一些機會
然後持續的去關注
但我覺得最好的情形還是
因為盤就已經在新高附近
就是趕快突破新高
然後記得大家射出去
這個就會變得很好處理
但如果沒有的話
我們真的就要開始去往外面
去找一些second tier
或是third tier的東西
然後看各位填補我們交易的一個空虛
大概這樣
那稍微跟大家分享一下
自己一下對市場的一些看法
那接下來進入Q的部分
第一位中節宣
孟公主角您好
2020年聽到現在的老聽眾來報道
那感謝孟公提供這麼好的節目
也從2020年聽您的建議
一頭大盤至今
爽翻了
2020到現在真的是爽到翻掉
他說只有一個想問的
黃顏路比有沒有要上PS5的計畫
愛您
昨天剛好跟八哥
就是Cupdog的Founder
有間沒有聊天
然後我幹了好幾個
黃顏路比的那叫什麼
胸身超開心
真的覺得超級可愛
他就跟我分享到說
他們在明年會上PlayStation
也會上Switch
所以如果你是家機的使用者
Yeah
可以玩到黃顏路比了
下面一位 Dumplings
所以安安你覺得我的大頭貼好看嗎
會想幫秋狗買頂鋼盔去保家餵果嗎
他大頭貼是狗帶著鋼盔
你這樣你看我真的也好想買個鋼盔給秋狗帶
下面一位
哈克最近太難學了
那我們做到生日快樂
希望他在美國要注意健康
保重身體持續下單給魏老闆謝謝MK對他們應該就是會持續下單給魏老闆沒錯但是在後段有一些規劃他們在Singapore那邊
現在是有自己的宅版
跟一些封裝的東西會拉到那邊去
但是在前端的部分
我覺得持續下單給魏老闆
是一個最主要的核心
沒錯
然後再講說
Semicon少了皮衣男之後
變得好冷清
也沒有冷清
不是超多人跑去嗎
但是我稍微的看了一下Memo
我想Memo是正經的Memo
不是Showgirl memo
那個超多人在喘
每年都有
我覺得很屌
就是一個展覽各自表述
大家都去看自己想看的東西
那稍微再看了一下之後
我覺得這次的東西
跟上一回的電腦展類似
我不是有提到說
竟然讓我最震驚的是
NVIDIA可能在消費這邊的東西
以前看都是看AI
那只是我覺得在過去的幾年
AI真的某個程度上
給你一種那種鈍化的味道了
就是我知道你有這種
有去你來看我就看過了
所以你也沒有真的給我看到
太多新的東西
或是你給我看到新的東西
可是新的東西出來是2029 2030
那就會變得是
我沒有辦法立即轉化到我的工作裡面
會有這樣的一個感受
所以這次蠻多去看Semicon的朋友
出來講的各種
我們就不去點名哪些題材
但看起來就是說都是ontrack
那有些東西甚至會比想像中的再慢一點
可是我們並沒有看到太多新的東西
但當然有蠻多朋友都反映說SOIC
然後或是各種有的沒有東西
直接整合包在一起就是大的趨勢
可是這個誰不知道
大家都知道說後面就是往這個方向去走
所以要再次的去重生而已
所以確實會稍微的覺得
好像看了
然後你也沒有真的
就是像以前一看就靈光乍現
回去馬上下單
連看那種人家設備後面的顏色是用哪一個
交換機是用誰
看到都好像看到什麼新的東西
像那時候去某ICD站在那邊
看他們的記憶方
你們是用這個東西
然後回去馬上下單
這種感覺已經是在
可能這一兩年就比較沒有了
所以你不要去很短視經歷
就跟我們節目的中末段講的一樣
如果你現在持續的去看著成績
然後好好的跟著
那都沒有什麼太大問題
但是你要過去的那種激情
我覺得可能也是因為
進入那種小小的中場休息吧
所以會感覺好像沒有辦法
給你看到一些刺激的東西
確實大家都有這樣的一個感受
那下面一位
Deku Monogongchika
本身交易做久了
對外越來越少跟別人談到交易
看到一堆怪小會很反感是正常的嗎
社群一堆7月底
跌破4萬航空的開客宅
授課價格都在比貴
每個都在講波浪理論
像4萬7又出來大小聲說自己都看對台灣法規容忍度真高應該把這些人都抓起來關才對褻瀆神聖的交易對啦 我以前也是屬於那種
會去開幹說一些什麼開客宅
或是一些那種詐騙宅
早期的節目會
後來我就比較不會了
因為老實講不是每個人都是詐騙
然後我們自己身邊有一些朋友
他們確實也是有一些這種收費的東西
收費的東西其實你不能夠說它是錯
我只能說因為台灣市場以前
發展的完整跟結構性還沒有很好
所以有很多是那種代進出的老師
然後這種就有問題
就算你跟我講說你是合法的
就是有拿到牌的投顧
你說我會推薦我身邊的一些
不懂交易市場的人
你去跟投顧嗎
大家心中也心裡有數
對吧
所以它也不是說什麼有牌沒牌的問題
是說我覺得這個也要某個程度上
進入一種專業分工
就是交易的東西
其實我認為不用花太多心力去討論
因為每個人都有自己的技法跟做法
但是如果你今天是出來跟大家分享一些產業的know how
你有一些產業的age
像那個semi analysis
你看它那個營收超級恐怖
我覺得他們賺這些錢就是非常非常合理的
我就去分享這些東西
讓他們出來開這種課是OK的
但是如果是出來跟大家說
我都會做我超越交易
這個就很奇怪
因為理論上你這麼會做這麼會交易
你怎麼會想賺這種小錢
就像我跟大家講的是
你在那種flex上面或是各個地方看到
什麼我要教你什麼
然後你真的相信的
你就是趕快去紅幹
因為很奇怪
怎麼覺得我會想要賺這種東西
甚至連節目的業配
有時候我心中都在想說
不知道網路上要收到一些人的批評
然後你知道他一整年的收入
而且我們講的是說都還沒有扣稅
什麼的沒有的
他都比不上一天的震盪
所以你真的有辦法在市場尻錢的人
你怎麼可能會想要去賺那些小錢
當然如果說你今天是另外的
就是你是學術性的研究性的
我覺得那個是沒有什麼太大的問題
但真的有蠻多人在褻瀆交易
確實是這樣
只是我已經是過了
就是想要去指教大家的事件點
年輕的時候會
下午覺得說反正
每個人都對著其他的遭遇
雖然聽起來很消極
但我現在的感受真的是這樣
就是有些人為什麼會這麼慘
以前人家講的
可依人之人必有可恨之處
你慢慢會懂這件事情
那你學會了什麼
你學會就是我就沉默就好
因為反正我也救不了你
我真的去救你我也會很累
因為觀念差太多
你會信那些東西的人
基本上就是很難救
就救不起來
就算你今天介紹一個
非常厲害的教育者給他
你信不信也會教到崩潰
真的是我們的感受是這樣子
因為我們也試著去服一些人
或是身邊的人
試著去服一些人
最後面大家的意見都是一樣
會就是會
不會就是不會下面一位Ying Cham請問為什麼鬼的形象大多是白色的為主而不是黑色因為黑鬼要工作他講的不是我講的沒有什麼想說的祝孟公哥全家大小一生平安快樂
那對了
蛋保新專輯上線可以買了
裡面還有附贈一款
蛋保自製的RPG音樂小遊戲
推薦給孟公哥
非常感謝你的推薦
沒有啦 貴也蠻多是黑色的
像我帶我老婆去冰島的一個飯店
就是他可以泡湯的那個飯店
他算是蠻高級蠻好的
可是不知道什麼
我老婆說在那邊卡到陰看到鬼
他就是在晚上睡覺的時候
然後看到天花板有很多黑色的細線掉下來
然後到回到台灣
都一直看到那個黑色細線
晚上就一直會把我叫醒說
他又看到鬼或什麼的
所以是有黑色的鬼沒錯啦
下面一位跳跳奶頭
欸他又回來了
大家好我是會跳的奶頭
簡稱跳跳奶頭
大家今天過得好嗎
小奶頭猛攻
蝦股市常常出現劇烈震盪
不是為什麼要叫小奶頭猛攻啦
我有個問題想要認真請教你
最近跟朋友去幫女生搬家具
我問說就這些要幫忙嗎
女生說有勞二位
我明明洗乾淨了為什麼還有味道
世界真的很大
下面一位黑人給我閉嘴歐巴馬
夢功好目前已經步入職場
算蠻長一段時間了
很幸運的在工作跟投資上
都有穩定順利的發展
在經濟有餘力的下
體驗了各種美食
乖好我是吃貨
也很慶幸在過去幾年跟老婆以及一群好友
去完成人生的各種 bucket list
但最近突然對這個世界失去了興趣
想去的地方都去過了
吃到好吃了可能就不再這麼高興
遇到好事或是壞事也不容易有情緒起伏
想請問夢夢有遇到這種狀況嗎?
雖然您說無聊是幸福的事
但我此刻好像並不是特別的幸福
是我太不知足了嗎?
感謝主委祝主委一家
平安順行 績笑 彭高高
這位兄弟就是我的陣頭
我不是很常跟大家分享說
我超羨慕那一種
可能每個週末他知道說
我去打個球
不管什麼籃球啊
高爾夫什麼
他就覺得說
這個就是我一直在做的事情
我做了十幾年很開心
我也是沒有這樣的東西
所以我也是屬於說
持續去探索的那種心態
因為我沒有一個
我真的固定很喜歡的事情
所以最後面每個東西都會有一點
像是這種玩膩的感覺
但我的解放
而且也不是說
我為了解這件事情去解說
而是我意外的發現
因為孩子就整天會把你出新的東西
他有一些新的反應
或是隨著不同的年齡增長
開始遇到一些新的事情
它反而是我覺得在過去的數年
最充實的事情
像我昨天就有一件事情超級感動
反正總之我去玩
Startup Sphere的活動
然後回來之後呢
兒子在路上就開始打電話說
爸爸你怎麼還沒有回家
就開始在那邊吹
就跟以前一樣
後來因為我妹剛好在隔壁跟他講話
就說不然我們消去接爸爸
因為剛好我的東西送到了
我們下去拿然後順便接爸爸
然後我期待就是我妹會帶我的大兒子下來
結果我一下子就發現說
我全家都下來了
我老婆也下來
然後我小兒子也下來
然後大兒子直接衝上來給我抱抱
小兒子就抱抱
他就只會講抱就一個字
他也要抱
然後其實他們兩個就為了爭奪我的注意力
就開始吵架
一個在哭
一個就開始大叫不准
滴滴什麼的
這個是我可能
我不知道就二三十年來最幸福的一刻
突然覺得說太幸福了吧
這種事情真的可以發生在我身上
所以我覺得每個人都會找到
這樣的一個時刻
我並不是鼓勵你說
趕快去交配生小孩
我意思是說
在你最不期待的地方
你沒有想到的地方
因為這個在沒有孩子的生活
我是不知道會這樣子的
有些事情就發生了
類似這樣
但你有可能會找到某種興趣
或是你去了一個超級喜歡的國家
或是某一個餐廳
然後突然間覺得
這個就是我一生在找的東西
是有機會遇到
所以我們要做的事情就是
我盡量的去減少自己能量的發散
我盡量的去把自己的注意力
視為是一個很重要的事情
所以一些對話
不想回了就不要回了
一些信不想回了就不要回了
你也不要去擔心說什麼
別人覺得你難相處什麼的
我覺得這個有效
你先把自己的能量盡量的聚在一起
因為你只要每次對外開口
你只要每次去回憶人家
或者人家把一些東西丟到你身上
那個都是一個能量的消耗
你先把能量都控起來
然後接著就想說慢慢的比氣長
你總是會找到一個好的東西
這個是我後來再做的一個方向給你參考
那下面一位
R
夢宮祝賀安
我是小您三個月又兩天的氣氛仔
感謝您一直以來分享生活日常股市資訊
也很喜歡聽您分享各種心態轉變的想法
祝福何家健康平安順心
生日快到
希望您可以跟我說那四個字
無湯咖啡
也請觀音大保佑我未來轉職成功
若願望成真將分級捐出一個月的薪水
給流氧動物相關機構
也願三重木木媽媽備孕一切安好
早日迎來好消息
我們希望木木媽媽備孕順利
也希望你可以順利的轉職成功
生日快樂
下面一位全職投資人MK
上週感謝念我留言
忘了祝您全家一切平安順行
非常感謝大家的各種正念
持續的灌到我身體裡
下面一位Iris1980MK您好想要請問您覺得從事事酒師這份工作有什麼建議吗我的朋友20岁在私人的发餐当后厨实习一年最近老板给了他机会向客人介绍红酒
他开始思考自己是否要转换身份
他的性格开朗
喜欢在一线跟客人接触沟通
于是想往事酒师的这一行前进
担心语言不够好
所以先去澳洲的酒厂打工开始
但因为他本身家庭经济条件很好
我们在想他可以直接上
法国参除学院会更有效率
目前老板是让他留下
并签两年的合约做培训
想问MK可以给建议吗
我是觉得你各位不用去担心
那些家境很好的人
要怎么样规划他的未来
因为他们有非常低的试错成本
所以他们可以慢慢的去试
这就是有些人他先天的一种优势
所以你不用想太多
他的直觉是怎么样
他就往那个方向去就好
所以我覺得他一定會有辦法長得很好
因為家庭給他一個很強大的後盾跟安全網
可是同時他自己都知道自己要幹嘛
他有他想要去試的方向
也不要去想說做哪件事情比較有CP值
或是條件比較好
就是你想說這樣更有效率
沒有 有效率是我們這些窮鬼要去想的事情
怎麼樣的快速的吃飯
怎麼樣快速的去跟人家競爭
怎麼樣快速的去產出一個產品
可以很快的收益
是我們這些窮鬼的任務
真正的已經是有餘裕的人
他們是可以慢慢來的
而且他們可能會做得比我們好
為什麼
因為你後來會發現
像我剛剛前面回答那位聽眾所講的
注意力真的是一個超級重要的資產
但很多人正在把它無情的往外放
其實我覺得說你的注意力
你要去看一些幹片影音什麼都還好
主要是你一直去跟人家互動
這真的會把你的注意力燒掉
他真的會把它燒掉
除非你是那種依人
就是你出現跟人家互動
然後是會加分的
不然你其實是盡可能的
要把這個能量守回來
所以這些人
因為他平常沒有什麼東西需要擔心
所以他有很多的時間可以去思考
這些思考都會產生很多有趣的想法
這也是我近年才有的感受
因為在早些幾年我也沒有時間去思考
我整天都在衝
所以我才會發生說
那時候講可能有些人也會覺得很怪
我老婆說我們就去西班牙哪個地方
我們就去做簡單的工作
然後這樣去生活就好
然後我就是哭著跟她講說
他媽的我再也不要再窮回去
因為我們經歷過
所以我不想要那樣
但是我現在如果老婆再一次跟我提這個
我想說可以喔
走啊一起去掃條
我最喜歡掃條
以前當兵在迎戰的時候
幫忙盤點掃條碼
可能還蠻快樂的
你的想法就會去改變
所以他們會有更開闊的世界然後他們會更有辦法去嘗試一些大家不敢嘗試的東西即便看起來你想說CP值太低了吧你怎麼會先去做一個什麼基層的工作
但就是因為他去做這些基層的工作
然後搭配他的資源跟實力
他搞不好會蹦出一些新的職位
你懂我意思嗎
所以你不用為了要擔心
我覺得他選的方向蠻有趣的
雖然可能在未來的趨勢上
目前還不一定
因為紅酒他其實是一個
正在進入一個我覺得構造改革
就是過往的那些Big Names
是對於我們這些真的有病的
才會想要去搞
其實蠻多年輕人他叫什麼自然酒
他們去玩新的東西
他對那些Big Names
他想說你們把它吵得這麼高
有些要什麼配額
要怎麼樣的
你們死老人有錢的
你去玩你家的事
我家都去找一些新銳酒莊
所以他也在慢慢的轉變
你可能就是說
如果說可以搭上轉變一些思維
然後你去做出一些新一代的人
他們會喜歡的東西
其實我覺得這是一個很好的轉折點
所以你知道一些老人就會掛掉
老的思維老的不好的東西
就是要新陳代謝
如果他們都不代謝掉的話
怎麼會有新的東西出來
那為什麼
所以他可能
我覺得介入的時間點算不錯
因為有一種那種
構造改革的味道開始出來
下面一位
好想離職
孟公您好想請教
28歲 古06年
科技業年薪將近百萬
工作時間穩定
但開盤時間工作干擾多
盯盤的工具也有限
過去投資僅持平大盤
今年出本金400萬
至今靠投資達1600萬
也挺過了7月的行情
如果資產達2000萬並維持三到四個月
就轉全市投資
個股為主
月交易量於1億會太魯莽嗎
愛你
所以意思是說
之前都是大概平大盤
然後在今年突然間大爆發
400變1600
其實今年蠻多人都大爆發
然後重點是7月有沒有辦法守住
所以7月我覺得
如果你前面有大爆發
就是賺超過200%以上的
然後你桌盪大概在30-50%以內
我覺得都還蠻不錯的
就是以這個
因為它是一個特殊的行情
特殊的行情特殊做
特殊的回檔的額度
都算是可以被接受的
那這樣子有沒有辦法去轉全職
我覺得都可以試看看
只要說你的開銷是OK
其實都可以試看看
你知道嗎
因為我覺得只跟大家強調一個觀念
財富自由的關鍵是
你的物欲被控制的怎麼樣
如果說物欲就沒有很大的話
那當然是立刻就可以去做嘗試
物欲很大的話
你賺多少錢可能都不夠用
那可以試看看
但是還是要強調一件事情
就是全職交易它就是一門工作
你並不是說什麼逃避了一個工作
到一個很爽的地方
沒有
那個是一堆的慕名其妙想像
所以你才會被詐騙
他其實就是另外一門工作
而且可能會花更多錢更多時間但你可能花得很高興你知道說所有的助控權在你身上他最有價值的其實是這一段但這一段不是每個人都可以appreciate有些人還是會喜歡說
他要有別人跟他講說要做什麼事情
但如果你是對自我時間的需求是很高的
你可以去試看看
我覺得試一下沒有什麼大不了的
反正就是自己要去設定
某種stop loss的地方
賠到哪些地方就乖乖的回去上班
不要說整個都賠到沒有
因為其實在過往看到蠻多
我們自己身邊是比較還好
但是可能兩三層朋友線以外的
好像陪到要回去上班的
這個是不太好
就是說你不要說陪光才會上班
應該陪到某個位置
你就要知道說OK
我要守住我的戰果
然後接著我就乖乖的上班
然後穩穩的做好配置
這個可能是
只要有這樣的一個底線在
我覺得沒有什麼太大問題
都可以試看看
那下面一位Shana Lai
夢空大大您好
我和先生一起收聽節目四年
感謝一路的陪伴
分享生活跟育兒都很有趣
產業分析無沙沙
本身只會定期定額0050
和先生同學長
學生長跑13年進入婚姻
那現在還有一個超高電量的
3歲小男孩蜜甘
希望借您的金口祝福
9月7號生日的先生
aka蜜甘的帥氣爸爸
38歲生日快樂
也祝夢宮全家
聽眾平安快樂
自產翻倍
那我們祝爸爸生日快樂
也希望你們兩個可以繼續
百年好和平安順利
下面有位XY
來自馬來西亞的親家
MKHKA
我們是來自馬來西亞的聽眾
我男友自己的超級粉絲
連睡覺打攤
都可以把節目的內容
一次背熟的那一種
这个超能力无法解释想必是真爱
因为我讲了8万次用厕所记得冲水
他都忘记
Anyway在此想麻烦MK祝我男友生日快乐
愿他能够得到所有他值得的
一直都是那个蓬勃跟开朗的少年
好运常伴健康无忧
我们在一起这9年都on and off的远距离
但他一直都往美好的未来生活前进
我也一直感恩相遇
那这段关系充满了希望勇气
跟对未来生活的热爱
不管是有福或是更有福
在這生我們都只會越來越愛
也祝MK一家一直生活安康平安富裕
不然他前面講的都很像那種
三立的什麼愛語什麼的故事之類的
一些台詞
你是三立台來的是不是嗎
好我們祝你們一切順利
馬來西亞的蘭卡威
可能是我去過最喜歡的地方之一
那邊有個度假村叫達泰
超讚
真的直接跑到原始森林裡面
一堆猴子然後早餐很好吃
下面一位
待夜中的小菜雞
夢公主角你好
上週是我25歲
第一次出國
然後地震下大雨
班機延誤都遇到
小菜機我算誰嗎
不會一次遇到各種好玩的事情
你要這樣想
以及我在東京的車站大樓外
都會聽到很高頻的聲音
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕